David Boder: [In English] Italy, September 2nd, Tradate. A little community of displaced people living in a old castle which later was a convent and then a armory between Milano and Como. Uh, there is a number of community of kibbutzim that are co-operative groups of specially young people that have gotten together, mostly young people who have lost all their whole family and could not, did not feel, or could not stay in their place where their families were, uh, perished. They are roaming through Europe and form various groups, leaving homes, cross borders illegally, and here is a, uh, group that entered Italy and is being supported by the UNRRA and by the Joint. Uh, the interviewee is now, uh, Miss Toba Schiver, uh, 22 years old, born in Czechoslovakia.
David Boder: [In German] Also Fräulein, sind Sie ver-, sind Sie verheiratet?
Toba Schiver: Nein.
David Boder: Ja. Also, Fräulein Schiver. Wollen Sie mir noch einmal sagen, was ist Ihr voller Name, wo sind Sie geboren und wie alt sind Sie?
Toba Schiver: Bin geboren in Tschechoslowakei...
David Boder: [Unterbricht] Lauter und langsamer. Sie sind geboren in der Tschech-
Toba Schiver: [Unterbricht] in Tschechoslowakei. 22 geboren.
David Boder: Ja. Äh, was, und Sie sind 22 Jahre alt?
Toba Schiver: Alt.
David Boder: Alt. Nun, sagen Sie mir. Wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg hat sich angefangen, und was hat mit Ihnen passiert und mit Ihrer Familie? In Zeit, wenn der Krieg hat sich angefangen.
Toba Schiver: Nun. Einmal, äh, ge-, gefahren nach, äh, Mátészalka. In Ghetto.
David Boder: Also, warten Sie. Sind die Deutschen reingekommen zu Ihrem Platz?
Toba Schiver: Nee. Ungarn.
David Boder: Nein?
Toba Schiver: Ungarn hatten genom-, genommen uns. In Mátészalka,...
David Boder: Sie sind?
Toba Schiver: in Ghetto. Diese erste zusammen.
David Boder: Also, Sie waren in der Tschechoslowakei. Wie sind Sie gekommen nach Ungarn?
Toba Schiver: Dass, dass wir in Tschechoslowakei und, äh, nachher gekommen sechs Jahre in Ungarn.
David Boder: Wann?
Toba Schiver: Ungarn. Sechs Jahre waren wir in Ungarn.
David Boder: Und [unverständlich]. Nein, nein, nein.
Toba Schiver: Tschechoslowakei. Sechs Jahre wir waren Ungarn.
David Boder: Das heißt, die äh, die Ungarn haben das zugenommen?
Toba Schiver: Zugenommen.
David Boder: Also das ist die Sache. Das war ein Platz in der Tschechoslowakei, was, wenn die, äh, als sie angefangen haben, die Ungarn zugenommen von den Tschechoslowaken.
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Nun und was ist passiert? Man hat gemacht ein Ghetto?
Toba Schiver: Ein Ghetto in Mátészalka.
David Boder: In Mátészalka hat man gemacht ein Ghetto. Also erzählen Sie, wie hat man das bekannt gemacht, dass man macht es ein Ghetto und wie hat man Sie genommen zum Ghetto?
Toba Schiver: Man hat gefangen die Menschen in ein Ghetto und [unverständlich] Lager. Und, äh, vier Wochen sie zusammen gewesen.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Nachher, hat man gemacht ein Appell und die ganze Familie gemacht, äh, alle zugenommen, alle Sachen und alle ge-, weggeführt nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Wen, die ganze Familie?
Toba Schiver: Ganze Familie.
David Boder: Man hat nicht ausgelesen, welche sollen bleiben?
Toba Schiver: Nee, nee. [Unverständlich]
David Boder: [Unverständlich]. Was is-, ist eine Familie gewesen, wer seien sie gewesen. Vater, Mutter?
Toba Schiver: Vater, Mutter, Schwester.
David Boder: Eine Schwester?
Toba Schiver: Ein Schwester. Bru-, Bruder in Militär.
David Boder: Der Bruder ist gewesen in der tschechischen Militär.
Toba Schiver: Tschechische Militär.
David Boder: Ja. Nun weiter? So sind Sie gekommen nach wo?
Toba Schiver: Nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Also, wie viel Tage sind Sie gefahren nach Auschwitz?
Toba Schiver: Vier Tage. Kein, ein Brot hat vier Tage, ein Mensch.
David Boder: Ja? Nun, und?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich]. Bis Karshow haben wir die Ungarn beglei-. Nach Karshow hat zuge-, äh, übergenommen die Deutschen.
David Boder: Die SS?
Toba Schiver: Die SS.
David Boder: Oder die Wehrmacht?
David Boder: Die SS haben es übergenommen?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Toba Schiver: Und nachher gekommen nach, äh, nach Auschwitz. Hat man gesehen schon das Lager die große Feuer.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: und hat alles gemacht, ja. [Unverständlich] in die Waggonen...
Toba Schiver: und man hat es verteilt alte Menschen, kranke Menschen, junge Menschen extra.
David Boder: Nun, wie hat man verteilt Ihre Familie?
Toba Schiver: Meine Familie wird gekommen, ältere Vater, und ich bin zusammengegangen mit mein Mutter. Habe SS gesagt, dass meine Mutter ge-, Mutter kenn, kann, kennit laufen, du gehst extra.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Hat mich zu-, extra genommen...
David Boder: Ja.
Toba Schiver: und mein Schwester zusammen.
David Boder: Die Schwester war älter oder jünger?
Toba Schiver: Jünger, mit ein Jahre.
David Boder: Mit einem Jahr. Aber, warten Sie, Sie sind gefahren vier Tage?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Was für einen Waggonen hat man Euch gegeben?
Toba Schiver: Ähm.
David Boder: Äh, waren es Passagierwaggonen mit Sitzen, mit Bänken?
Toba Schiver: Nee, gar nicht, auf der Erd gesessen.
David Boder: Man hat gesessen auf der Erden.
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Wie viel Menschen waren es im Waggon?
Toba Schiver: Siebzig Menschen.
David Boder: Siebzig Menschen im Waggon. Männer mit Frauen zusammen?
Toba Schiver: Männer und Frauen und Kinder zusammen.
David Boder: Nun, hat man den Waggon abgeste-, ist stehen geblieben, wenn die Menschen sollen rausgehen?
Toba Schiver: Nein der hat, äh, ein, äh [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Ein, was, äh?
Toba Schiver: ein, äh,
David Boder: Ein Topf?
Toba Schiver: ein Topf.
David Boder: Ja, und?
Toba Schiver: Das hat man immer rundgeschickt.
David Boder: Und das hat man immer rausgeworfen.
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, weiter? Also sind Sie gekommen hat man den Vater ab-, äh, separate genommen und die Mutter.
Toba Schiver: Separate genommen, die Mutter extra und mein Schwester zusammen genehm ich.
David Boder: [Unterbricht: unverständlich].
Toba Schiver: Arbeitslager bin ich geblieben.
David Boder: Sie und die Schwester sind geblieben im Arbeitslager?
Toba Schiver: Ja. Und die Schwes-, der, der Vater auch in Arbeitslager.
David Boder: In Arbeitslager.
Toba Schiver: Aber die Mutter in Krematorium.
David Boder: Wissen Sie das bestimmt?
Toba Schiver: Ja. Wir haben gesehen in, äh, ein, äh, Großmutter gefahren mit ein schwarzen Auto zusammen.
David Boder: Wie? Ihre Großmutter?
Toba Schiver: Meine Großmutter.
David Boder: Ihre Mutter und die Großmutter hat man weggenommen,...
Toba Schiver: Wegge-
David Boder: und Sie haben kein Mal von denen nicht gehört?
Toba Schiver: Nee.
David Boder: Nein.
Toba Schiver: Wir haben gesehen, dass, wenn man hat das verbrennt.
David Boder: Was heißt, Sie haben gesehen?
Toba Schiver: [lauter werdend] In Krematorium wir haben gesehen, in Krematorium gehen das.
David Boder: [ungläubig] Ja, aber Sie haben doch nicht gesehen, dass man Ihre Mutter?
Toba Schiver: Meine Mutter nicht. Aber das ist bestimmt.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, weiter?
Toba Schiver: Mein Vater ist gegangen in die andere Seite, hat er gesehen, dass ich hab kein Mutt-[unverständlich]. Hat er gesagt [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Was?
Toba Schiver: [lauter werdend] mein, mein Vater
David Boder: hat gesagt
Toba Schiver: [unverständlich]. Er hat, wir wollten uns treffen...
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Dann wär ich nicht im Krematorium. [unverständlicher Satz]
David Boder: Wieso, der Vater ist doch gegangen zur Arbeit?
Toba Schiver: Zur Arbeit, aber er hat gesehen, dass wir nicht zusamm-, als, wir sind zusammen mit mein Mutter.
David Boder: Aha.
Toba Schiver: Verstehen Sie?
David Boder: Also, Sie, hat man Sie reingenommen im Lager dort?
Toba Schiver: Wir zum Lager.
David Boder: Was hat dort passiert?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] Lager, [unverständlich] zusammengekommen, ein, ein, ein Transport.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie ein bisschen lauter.
Toba Schiver: Und, äh, hat man uns ausgezogen [unverständlich] Ganze, hat mir gegeben [unverständlich] abgeschoren die Haare.
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Toba Schiver: Älte.
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen?
Toba Schiver: Männer.
David Boder: Männer haben Ihnen abgeschoren die Haare, nachdem sie ausgezogen?
Toba Schiver: Aus-, äh, ausgezogen haben die Haare.
David Boder: Aha. Und man hat [TS unterbricht: unverständlich] die Haare abgeschoren nur vom Kopf?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie, das muss man wissen!
Toba Schiver: Nein, man hat von überall die Haare.
David Boder: Und das haben Männer getan?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Nun was für ein, was haben sie gehabt, Scheren, Messer?
Toba Schiver: Scher-, Scheren haben sie gehabt.
David Boder: Waren es nicht Häftlinge, die es getan haben?
Toba Schiver: Nein, Älte haben das gemacht.
David Boder: Äh, haben sie was gesagt, während sie es getan haben?
Toba Schiver: Gar nicht. Man kann gar nichts machen, haben gleich geschlagen, dass [unverständlich] ausziehen.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, was hat denn passiert?
Toba Schiver: Nachher haben sie [unverständlich] baden...
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: und bekommen lange Kleider und [unverständlich], man hat ausgesehen so wie ein, wie ein, äh, nicht mehr Menschen. [Unverständlich] Ich hab gesehen mein Schwester, hat sie sich neben mit mir gestanden. Ich hab sie nicht erkennt.
David Boder: Aha?
Toba Schiver: Menschen, viele Menschen hab ich gesehen [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja. Man hat ihnen nicht gegeben männerische Kleider, nicht männerische Kleider?
Toba Schiver: Nicht nur lange Kleider, äh, ei-, zerrissene Kleider gegeben...
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: und, nachdem, äh, [unverständlich] nach einem Appell [unverständlich] und geführt ins, in ein Block.
David Boder: Was ist ein Appell, was ist es?
Toba Schiver: Auf, abzuzählen die Menschen...
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Toba Schiver: und so lang geht der Appell bis lang, zwei Stunden geht ein Appell.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und hatten ein, geführt uns ein Block [unverständlich], in ein Block.
Toba Schiver: So, na, wie in fünf Meter fünfzehn Mann hatten geschlafen.
David Boder: Fünfzehn Mann haben geschlafen auf fünf- ?
Toba Schiver: Fünfzehn, fünf äh Meter.
David Boder: Auf fünf Meter Breite?
Toba Schiver: Mehr gesessen als...
David Boder: Oh, man ist bloß gesessen?
Toba Schiver: gesessen.
David Boder: Ja.
Toba Schiver: Weil schlafen hat man nicht gekönnt.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und man hat...
David Boder: [Unterbricht] Sich hinlegen hat man nicht gekönnt?
Toba Schiver: Ja. Und nachdem ha-, man so angekommen ward, ni- gekrie- ni-, tag gar nichts essen.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und nachdem haben wir geschlafen die ganze Nacht und wir zwei über Nacht uns aufgeweckt Appell. Jeden Tag von zwei bis neun Uhr in Appell geführt.
David Boder: Von zwei bis neun in der Früh [unverständlich] Appell. Why so lang, warum [unverständlich]?
Toba Schiver: Warum, äh, seien, äh, sehr viel Appell, sehr viele Menschen gewesen, und ganze Lager [unverständlich], das ganze Auschwitz gewesen [unverständlich] at Appell [unverständlich] aufstehen [unverständlich] sehr viel Leute gewesen. Millionen Männer, äh, Frauen, äh Menschen gewesen.
David Boder: Tausende Menschen.
Toba Schiver: Tausende Menschen.
David Boder: Nun, weiter, und wer sind gewesen die Blockälteste?
Toba Schiver: Die, äh, Blockälteste sind gewesen polische und, äh, slowakische Juden [unverständlich] Juden.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Die Älteste sind schon sehr lange gewe-
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen?
Toba Schiver: Frauen Männer.
David Boder: Frauen und Männer?
Toba Schiver: Bei uns waren Frauen.
David Boder: Äh, jüdische-polnische Frau [unverständlich]?
Toba Schiver: Ja. Die, äh, die, äh, nur die Älteste sind gekommen jeden Tag, zu sagen was wir sollen tun.
David Boder: Ja, nun, und wie haben die sich benommen, die, äh, Blockälteste?
Toba Schiver: Sehr nett [oder: „nicht“] gut. Man hat hinzugenommen von Menschen Essen, was man Essen hatte, man hat herzugenommen...
David Boder: Warum, was haben Sie damit gemacht?
Toba Schiver: [unverständlich] hat er dann geschlagen.
David Boder: Die jüdische Frauen haben geschlagen die jüdische Mädchen?
Toba Schiver: Ja, ja diese Blockälteste. [Unverständlich] eine alte Frau. Haben Sie mir gesagt, meine Mutter hat mich schon immer geschlagen, ich schlage wegen Appell, ich schlage wegen Essen und [unverständlich] wegen Trinken immer geschlagen.
David Boder: Was heißt, haben Sie geschlagen, womit haben sie geschlagen?
Toba Schiver: Mit was, mit die Händ, mit allem. Mir haben die [unverständlich] auch geschlagen.
David Boder: Wer, eine Frau hat Sie [unverständlich] geschlagen?
Toba Schiver: Eine Frau.
David Boder: Eine jüdische Frau?
Toba Schiver: Eine von den SS, welche schon zehn Jahre hier in dem Lager.
David Boder: Eine SS Frau?
Toba Schiver: Eine SS Frau.
David Boder: Von was hat sie es getan?
Toba Schiver: Von gar nichts. [Unverständlich]. Mit Holz hat sie mir das angeschlagen, von gar nichts.
David Boder: No, weiter?
Toba Schiver: No, was?
David Boder: Also, das äh...
Toba Schiver: Ja, ach ja, wir haben gesehen leider die, äh, Krematorien die ganze Nacht, hat [unverständlich] Nacht gebrennt.
David Boder: Äh, wie hat das ausgesehen, die Krematorien? Wie haben das ausgesehen mit dem Brennen? Was waren es Schornsteine, äh?
Toba Schiver: Das weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Aber, ich mein, wo haben sie das Feuer gesehen?
Toba Schiver: Sie waren nicht weit von uns.
David Boder: Nicht weit...
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Es wird von [unverständlich] gespeist?
Toba Schiver: Von [unverständlich] gespeist.
David Boder: Nun, sind das die gleichen gewesen wie im Lager?
Toba Schiver: Diese Menschen [unverständlich] meine Mutter. Man hat erzählt [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja nun, was?
Toba Schiver: Diese Frauen, [unverständlich] haben sie die Särge gemacht. [unverständlich] Handtücher [unverständlich]. Wir haben ge-[unverständlich] Wasser, dann kommen die Gas.
David Boder: Gas. Nun?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] Gas haben sie verbrennt die Menschen.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: [Stöhnt].
David Boder: Nun, wie, äh, wie hat, wie lange hat das gedauert, das war in Auschwitz, ja?
Toba Schiver: In Auschwitz sind wir gewesen neun Wochen.
David Boder: Neun Wochen? Und hat man dort gearbeitet?
Toba Schiver: Nie gearbeitet, noch, sehr schlecht, dass wir in, ja. Wasser haben wir gedurft trinken.
David Boder: [unterbricht: unverständlich]?
Toba Schiver: Wer hat getrinken hat bekommen, äh, Bluten in, äh, im Maul.
David Boder: Warum?
Toba Schiver: Hat er, kein guter Wasser.
David Boder: Oh, dann bekommen Sie Blut im Maul?
Toba Schiver: Nie gut. Das Klima.
David Boder: Die Klima war nicht gut. Und man hat bekommen Blut im Maul vom Wasser? Wie kriegt man das Blut im Mund vom Wasser? Ist es geschwollen, oder was?
Toba Schiver: Nein, man kann nicht essen, ganz selten, kann nicht trinken, alles das.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Toba Schiver: Und die Sonne auch nicht gut. Von die Sonne bekommen Blusen [Anmerkung: sie meint „Blasen“] die Händ und Füß.
David Boder: Die Sonne?
Toba Schiver: Sonne nicht gut gewesen. Bekommen Blusen.
David Boder: Blasen an die Händ und die Füßen. Weiter?
Toba Schiver: Und, äh, man noch einmal bekommen ein, äh, Appell, dass man braucht Menschen.
David Boder: Ja? [Unverständlich]?
Toba Schiver: Nach [unverständlich], nach, äh, von Auschwitz weg.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Sind gefahren nach Geislingen.
David Boder: Wie werden sie ausgewählt, wer ist gefahren?
Toba Schiver: Ja. Zweimal, aber dreimal [unverständlich] Doktor, äh, immer gesehen. Der hat ein, gehabt ein kleiner Hund [unsicher], zurückgefahren.
David Boder: Was hat man mit denen gemacht?
Toba Schiver: Bitte?
Toba Schiver: Die sind geblieben noch in, äh, Auschwitz, mehr weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja. Nun, haben Sie, haben Sie genommen?
Toba Schiver: Mich haben genommen mit meiner Schwester. Immer gesehen mein Schwester, Familien zusammen.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und man hat ein Transport uns abgewaschen, man hat uns abge-[unverständlich] und neue Kleider gegeben und gefah-
David Boder: Was heißt neue Kleider?
Toba Schiver: Andere Kleider.
David Boder: Andere Kleider.
Toba Schiver: und sind wir gefahren nach Geilingen.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und nach Geislin-, Geislingen...
David Boder: [Unterbricht] Wie viel Tage ist man gefahren nach Geislingen?
Toba Schiver: Drei Tage.
David Boder: Und, äh, wie ist mit gefahren dieselbe Weg auf dieselbe Weise wie sie sind gekommen nach Auschwitz?
Toba Schiver: Nein,...
David Boder: Wie?
Toba Schiver: andere.
David Boder: Aber wie viel Personen in ein Waggon?
Toba Schiver: Achtzig Menschen.
David Boder: Achtzig Menschen!
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, Männer und Frauen zusammen?
Toba Schiver: Nein, nicht wir immer nur Männ-, Frauen gewesen.
David Boder: Nur Frauen gewesen. Nun weiter?
Toba Schiver: Und wir haben bekommen Viertel Brot am Tag...
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: und ein Stückl Margarine.
David Boder: Ja.
Toba Schiver: Und dann, wenn wir abgefahren nach, äh, Geislingen, wenn wir bekommen ein Bett [unverständlich]
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Toba Schiver: . . . ein Handtuch und ein Schüssel zu essen, ein Löffel [unverständlich], in Auschwitz haben wir gehabt kein Löffel, gar nichts.
David Boder: Wie hat man gegessen in Auschwitz?
Toba Schiver: Von ein Schüssel haben gegessen fünf Menschen.
David Boder: Und wie, ohne Löffel?
Toba Schiver: Ohne Löffel [unverständlich].
David Boder: Haben die Leute gegessen?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Aber wie hat man gegessen, fünf Menschen? Wie essen fünf Menschen?
Toba Schiver: [aufgeregt] Keine [unverständlich] getrinken [unverständlich].
David Boder: Getrunken, ein Suff genommen, ja?
Toba Schiver: Kein Löffel nicht gesehen.
David Boder: Yes?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] nach Geislingen haben wir bekommen ein, äh, Löffel und, äh, Messer [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun?
Toba Schiver: Nun, wir haben ni- gearbeitet vier Wochen. Haben gesehen, wie alt und schwach die Menschen.
David Boder: Ja.
Toba Schiver: [unverständlich] gearbeitet in Munitionsfabrik.
David Boder: Also noch mal. Also vier Wochen hat man nicht gearbeitet und man hat der Leuten [unverständlich], sich zu erholen. Ja. Und man hat, wie hat man sich benommen? Hat man euch gehalten besser?
Toba Schiver: Gut. Besser wie in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Wer waren die Blockältesten?
Toba Schiver: Blockälteste Christ.
David Boder: Christen. Hat man euch geschlagen?
Toba Schiver: Auch geschlagen, aber einfach besser wie in Auschwitz.
David Boder: [Lacht] Besser geschlagen [unverständlich]. Besser sich benommen?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: No, weiter?
Toba Schiver: Und nachher, nach, äh, vier Wochen sind gefah-, äh, gegangen in, äh, Munitionsfabrik.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: In die Tagschicht, Nachtschicht. Zwölf Stunden gearbeitet.
Toba Schiver: Sehr schwere Maschinen gewesen, diese verschiedenen Munitionen.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: [Einige Worte unverständlich] haben wir immer bekommen [unverständlich] Essen [unverständlich]. Und, äh,
David Boder: Also, wie lange hat das gedauert?
Toba Schiver: Ein Jahre.
David Boder: Ein Jahr.
Toba Schiver: In Geislingen.
David Boder: In Geislingen
Toba Schiver: Und immer [unverständlich] Amerikaner [unverständlich] Russen [unverständlich].
David Boder: Man hat weggeführt weiter von Geislingen?
Toba Schiver: Gefahren nach, nach, äh, Allach.
David Boder: Ja. Waren dort Selektionen in Geislingen?
Toba Schiver: Weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Hat man da rausgenommen die Schwachen und die Kranken?
Toba Schiver: Das, also die schwangere Frauen.
David Boder: Die Schwangeren?
Toba Schiver: Die schwangere Frauen noch einmal nach Auschwitz ge-, weggefahren.
David Boder: [bestürzt] Oh, die schwangeren Frauen sind weg von?
Toba Schiver: Ja, nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Toba Schiver: Und die, die Kranke selbstverständlich haben gestorben.
David Boder: Dort? Ja?
Toba Schiver: [unverständlich] im Revier.
David Boder: Was heißt auf einem Revier? Sind sie von selbst gestorben oder was?
Toba Schiver: Nee. Sie, äh, bekommen kein Medizin, sind sie krank, haben sie gestorben.
David Boder: Aha. Nun?
Toba Schiver: Gefahren nach Allach. [Unverständlich] jüdische Männer.
David Boder: Wohin?
Toba Schiver: Männer, zusammen mit die Männer. Aber mit die [unverständlich]. Zwei Wochen [unverständlich].
David Boder: Wie hat der gehei-, ist der Platz gehießen, Allach?
Toba Schiver: Allach.
David Boder: Aha.
Toba Schiver: Und, äh, dann hat, äh, ge-, äh, geschlagen [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: und der hat ge-, äh, geschlagen uns [unverständlich].
David Boder: Bitte, ja?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja, weiter? Reden Sie lauter ein bisschen.
Toba Schiver: Und, äh, so sind wir gefahren nach, äh. Nein, äh, [unverständlich] kein Essen gegeben. Gefahren zehn Tage in äh,
David Boder: Waggon,
Toba Schiver: Waggon, machen sie [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich]. Man hat geschlagen uns zehn Tage...
Toba Schiver: in Waggon und kein Essen und immer geschlagen uns.
David Boder: Na warten Sie. Wie hält man das durch zehn Tage in einem Waggon ohne Essen?
Toba Schiver: Man hat viel gestorben.
David Boder: [ungläubig]Und Sie haben wirklich nicht gegessen?
Toba Schiver: Wir bekommen einmal ein kleines Stückl Brot.
David Boder: No. Und Ihre Schwester war mit ihnen?
Toba Schiver: Ja, immer zusammen.
David Boder: Das heißt einmal am Tag oder einmal in die zehn Tage?
Toba Schiver: Einmal am Tag, ei-, aber, ei- so ein kleine [unverständlich], das ist so ein kleines.
David Boder: [In English] She shows a piece of a few inches square
Toba Schiver: [In German] Und dann...
David Boder: No?
Toba Schiver: auf einmal kommt ein, äh, ein Amerikaner von, äh, na ein Amerikaner vielleicht, vom Roten Kreuz und er kommt uns ein Päckl, ein Paket [unverständlich].
David Boder: Aha. Ein Amerika-, ein Mann vom Roten Kreuz und hat gegeben ein Päckl [unverständlich]. Zu jedem ein Päckl?
Toba Schiver: Jedem ein Päckl und da für jeden ein vielleicht zwei Kilo rein, ein Kilo.
David Boder: Was war da drin?
Toba Schiver: Milch und dann, äh, Fleischkonserve, Schokolade, und, äh, Seife, Zigaretten, und äh Butter,
David Boder: Aha, äh
Toba Schiver: und Stangenzucker.
David Boder: Was für ein Milch-, Milchpul-, Milch, äh, -pulver?
Toba Schiver: Pulver.
David Boder: Hat man da gegeben Wasser, äh, zusammenzumischen?
Toba Schiver: Das ist schon gewesen, Wasser, das haben wir gekonnt.
David Boder: Das war noch mit die Deutschen?
Toba Schiver: Mit die Deutschen.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und der SS-Mann, dass viele haben bekommen ein Befehl [unverständlich], damit die 3000 Männer, 3000 Menschen sollen, sollen viel in, äh, in Wald und ausschießen uns.
David Boder: Äh, wer hat es ihnen gesagt? [Unverständlich].
Toba Schiver: Wir haben das gesehen. Wir haben das gesehen.
David Boder: Was gesehen? Den Befehl?
Toba Schiver: Befehl. Haben es gesehen.
David Boder: Was, hat er es aufgeschrieben, Sie haben es gelesen, ja?
Toba Schiver: Selber frei geworden.
David Boder: Ah, Sie, Sie sind befreit worden?
Toba Schiver: Er hat mir das aufgezeigt.
David Boder: Er hat es aufgezeigt.
Toba Schiver: Von der SS.
David Boder: Ja, und wieso hat er das aufgezeigt [unverständlich]?
Toba Schiver: Nein und nachdem am anderen Tag einmal hören wir das Schießen und die Amerikaner sind angekommen. Geblieben ist der Waggon. Dann hat es geheißen man soll zumachen die Waggonen, was machen alles mit die vielen, äh, Waggone?
David Boder: Das soll heißen was?
Toba Schiver: Die, äh, SS haben zugemacht die, nein, jeden Waggon achtzig Menschen...
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: und jeden Waggon geblieben waren zwei SS.
David Boder: Im Waggon!
Toba Schiver: Im Waggon. Zwei SS.
David Boder: Mit den Freien?
Toba Schiver: Mit den Freien.
David Boder: Nun?
Toba Schiver: Immer zwei SS.
David Boder: Ach, beim Fahren auch?
Toba Schiver: Ja, es waren immer, immer.
David Boder: Immer zwei SS?
Toba Schiver: Immer. Sie haben uns gar nicht gesagt [unverständlich] und alle SS haben rausgenommen die, na diese Zeichen, dass sie mit SS, die äh
David Boder: Haben heruntergenommen ihre SS Zeichen.
Toba Schiver: Gar nicht gemacht, gar nicht gesagt sonst, aber wir haben schon gesehen, dass [unverständlich]. Und auf einmal hören wir das Schießen.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und [unverständlich], also haben wir zugemacht die Waggon. Sollen uns nicht [unverständlich] die Kleider,...
Toba Schiver: die [unverständlich] Kleider.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und hab bekommen ein, äh, Befehl [unverständlich]. Wir haben sehr Angst gehabt, haben wir ein Kleid aufgehangen auf den Waggon.
David Boder: Von außen?
Toba Schiver: Ja, dass wir sind Häftling.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und auf einmal wird gekommen ein, äh, ein Amerikaner und befreit geworden.
David Boder: Nun, wurden festgenommen?
Toba Schiver: Nein. Und alle SS haben sich alle [unverständlich], also...
David Boder: Die Hände herauf
Toba Schiver: die Hände herauf. Und er hatte gezeigt diese Zettel, dass da kommt ein Befehl, dass er soll sie ausschießen. Darum hat ihn gelasst frei.
David Boder: Was?
Toba Schiver: Gelasst frei, der SS.
David Boder: Man hat den SS freigelassen?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Weil er nicht die
Toba Schiver: Juden, äh,
David Boder: äh, vernichtet hat.
Toba Schiver: vernichtet. Aber die anderen vernichtet alle.
David Boder: Wer?
Toba Schiver: Die SS. Die Amerikaner.
David Boder: Haben sie geschossen?
Toba Schiver: Geschossen. [Unverständlich, TS und DB sprechen gleichzeitig]
David Boder: Die Amerikaner haben geschossen die SS?
Toba Schiver: Die SS.
David Boder: Und der Mann, der den Brief gehabt hat, war was, der Kommandierende [unverständlich]?
Toba Schiver: Der kommandiert, dass die 3000, äh, Menschen [unverständlich] in den Waggonen sollen ausschießen,
David Boder: Aha.
Toba Schiver: vernichten.
David Boder: Und Sie haben, gesehen wie die Amerikaner haben tot geschossen die SS?
Toba Schiver: Die SS.
David Boder: Haben die SS was gesagt, haben sie gebeten [unverständlich]?
Toba Schiver: Gar nicht [unverständlich].
David Boder: Aha. Nun?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] Wohnung, zu Essen, aber wir sind, sie haben gar nicht gemacht für uns.
David Boder: Was?
Toba Schiver: Die Amerikaner gar nicht gemacht für uns.
David Boder: Aha, was haben sie?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] wir haben selbst gemacht, allein.
David Boder: Was haben sie getan, was hat man getan?
Toba Schiver: Die Menschen, die Amerikaner sind weg von uns.
David Boder: [Unterbricht] und Sie?
Toba Schiver: Wir blieben allein. [Unverständlich].
David Boder: [Unterbricht] Nun, was haben Sie denn getan?
Toba Schiver: Welche Menschen gegangen alleine versorgen Essen, aber es war viele, welche nicht [unverständlich] geben Quartier, die Amerikaner, wollten sie geben Menschen Kleidung [unverständlich] allein gehabt, allein genehmen [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und was hat man genommen? Von wo hat man genommen?
Toba Schiver: Von den deutschen Wohnung.
David Boder: Von den deutschen. Sie sind reingegangen in die Häuser?
Toba Schiver: Und man hat genommen.
David Boder: Ja. Seien die Deutschen gewesen zu Hause, äh, die Leute?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Und was haben sie gesagt?
Toba Schiver: Gar nichts. Haben immer geweint.
David Boder: Die Deutschen haben geweint.
Toba Schiver: Ja. Seien ja nicht schuldig. Waren die SS, die haben das gemacht. Hatten nicht Schuld.
David Boder: Aber man hat genommen, was man gekönnt.
Toba Schiver: Nein, genommen aber, ich hab nicht genommen. Ich habe immer gedenkt, dass meine Eltern [unverständlich].
David Boder: Sie haben immer was?
Toba Schiver: Gedenkt, dass mein Eltern haben nicht gedenkt, [verbessert sich] nicht genommen.
David Boder: Sie haben nicht genommen. Und die Schwester war mit ihnen?
Toba Schiver: Ja, zusammen.
David Boder: Nun, weiter?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] zwei Wochen und wir sind befreit worden in Staltach.
David Boder: In Stahldach?
Toba Schiver: Staltach.
David Boder: Stalbach?
David Boder: Staltach. Nun?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] wir sind da gewesen vier Wochen. Wir haben gewartet dort zu ein tschechische Transporter und wir können viel fahren.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und auf einmal gefahren nach Feldafing.
David Boder: Feldafing?
Toba Schiver: Feldafing. Und dort haben wir dann mit tschechische, tschechische Transportmenschen dann gefahren. Ich hab, ich hab ein Kleid, ich bin gekommen mit ein Pyjama...
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Bis Tschechei.
David Boder: Ohne Kleid?
Toba Schiver: Ohne Kleid [unverständlich], ich hab keine gehabt.
David Boder: Und Sie haben nicht, warum haben Sie nicht genommen von die Deutschen?
Toba Schiver: Ich hab nicht gekonnt.
David Boder: Und ihre Schwester?
Toba Schiver: Schwester auch nicht.
David Boder: Nun?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] gekommen zu Hause, haben getroffen ni- mein Vater, nur ein Bruder.
David Boder: Was?
Toba Schiver: Tschechische Militär. Ein Bruder.
David Boder: Ja, aber den Vater haben sie nich-
Toba Schiver: Nicht getroffen. Gestorben.
David Boder: Und der Bruder ist zu Hause gekommen von?
Toba Schiver: Er ist in Militär gehen, tschechische. Aus dem tschechischen Militär.
David Boder: Haben Sie, wo haben Sie ihn gefunden?
Toba Schiver: In Tschechei. In Prag.
David Boder: Oh, war er dort?
Toba Schiver: War er dort.
David Boder: Und da war er Soldat?
Toba Schiver: War er Soldat.
David Boder: Nun, weiter?
Toba Schiver: Nun, nachdem wir sind gekommen zusammen, wir genommen ein, eine Wohnung. Gekommen [unverständlich] in der Ukraine...
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: zu der Ukraine.
Toba Schiver: Familie wollten dort bleiben. Hat ni- gewollt nach Prag.
David Boder: Ja. Sie hat nicht gewollt nach Prag?
Toba Schiver: Nicht zu Hause bleiben [unverständlich] die Ukraine. [Unverständlich]
David Boder: [Unverständlich].
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] ni- gewollt zurückgehen.
David Boder: Man hat nicht gewollt zurückzugehen.
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Was?
David Boder: Sie müssen besser wissen. Ihr seid nach, zu Hause gekommen nach eurem ei-, eigenen Städtl?
Toba Schiver: Ja, aber man kann nicht dort zurückgehen in das, äh, Haus.
David Boder: Wenn einem das Haus gehört?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Was es euer eigene Haus?
Toba Schiver: Eigene Hof. Eigene Hof. Wir waren dort acht Häuser.
David Boder: Acht Häuser habt ihr gehabt?
Toba Schiver: Aber, aber die Ukraine, das Ukraine das ist Kolchose. Das kann man nicht verlieren. Das ist nicht mein, das ist ganze Staat.
David Boder: Aha, die Ukraine sind geworden Kommunisten.
Toba Schiver: Kommunisten. Das ich habe zu Ukraine gehen [unverständlich]. Mein Bruder [unverständlich] in Prag.
David Boder: Ja, so?
Toba Schiver: Und so bin ich gefahren zu mein Bruder.
David Boder: Sie und Ihre Schwester zusammen?
Toba Schiver: Ich und mein Schwester, immer zusammen mit mein Schwester. Wir sind gefahren zusammen bis Prag und dort haben wir getroffen mein Bruder.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Und er [unverständlich].
David Boder: Wie haben Sie sich denn getroffen, wo haben Sie das denn gefunden?
Toba Schiver: In Prag.
David Boder: Ja, wussten Sie ein Adress?
Toba Schiver: Ja, er hat uns geschickt noch zu, von zu Hause ein Adress. Er hat nicht ge-, gewusst wo ist die Adress.
David Boder: Ja?
Toba Schiver: Er hat [unverständlich] nach Prag.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Toba Schiver: und so haben wir ge-, genommen ein Wohnung, und drei Menschen haben da gewohnt. Bruder, Schwester [unverständlich]. Und nachdem haben wir gearbeitet in ein Schokoladenfabrik.
David Boder: Schokoladenfabrik, at the Czech?
Toba Schiver: At the Czech. Sehr ein guter Leben dort gewesen.
David Boder: Nun, und denn? Warum, wie, wann haben Sie beschlossen wegzugehen?
Toba Schiver: Wir haben beschlossen, als man hat gesagt, dass die, dass man kann nicht, äh, bleiben, dass die russische Juden kann nicht bleiben in Tschechei.
David Boder: Oh, wer hat das gesagt? Die Tschechen?
Toba Schiver: Man hat gesagt.
David Boder: Ah, aber nicht offiziell.
Toba Schiver: Nicht offiziell.
David Boder: [Unverständlich].
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich]. Hab ich beschlossen, dass ich fahr nach Palästina.
David Boder: Nun, der Bruder auch?
Toba Schiver: Nein. Bruder ist nach Tschechei. Er hat geheiratet [unverständlich].
David Boder: Er hat geheiratet bei jüdische Mädel?
Toba Schiver: Jüdische Mädel.
David Boder: Und er ist dort geblieben?
Toba Schiver: [sie wird sehr leise] Dort geblieben.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter. Er ist dort geblieben. Und Sie mit die Schwester?
Toba Schiver: Wir sind hier. Die Schwester hat schon geheiratet, äh, sie hat schon einen Mann.
David Boder: Hier in?
Toba Schiver: in Tradate.
David Boder: In Tradate. Hat sie geheiratet hier in Tradate?
Toba Schiver: Nee, in Venezia hat sie geheiratet.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, warte, äh, warte ein bisschen. Nicht so schnell. Ihr habt jetzt beschlossen zu gehen nach Palästina?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Nun. Wie habt ihr sich angeschlossen, wie seid ihr bekommen Mitglieder von ein Kibbuz? Wie habt ihr sich angeschlossen ein Kibbuz? Wie seid ihr?
Toba Schiver: Von Prag in Wien.
David Boder: In Wien? Von Prag seid ihr gegangen nach Wien. Und wie habt ihr gefunden ein Kibbuz?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich] sind diese Menschen immer genommen, ein paar Menschen, die suchten ein Kibbuz.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, und denn von Wien seid ihr wieder weggegangen?
Toba Schiver: Nach Enns. Von Enns bis Linz.
David Boder: Enns?
Toba Schiver: Ah ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Toba Schiver: Nach ein Kibbuz zwei Wochenende gefahren.
David Boder: Gefahren oder gegangen?
Toba Schiver: Gefahren.
David Boder: Und denn von Linz, von Linz nach?
Toba Schiver: Nach Salzburg.
David Boder: Nach Salzburg. Und von Salzburg?
Toba Schiver: Nach, äh, Innsbruck. Von Innsbruck nach, äh, Milan.
David Boder: Nach Milan. Nun, äh, sagt mir, unterwegs wie habt ihr gegessen, wovon habt ihr gelebt?
Toba Schiver: Einfach immer gegeben. Von Enns nach Salzburg immer gegeben zu Essen auf dem Weg.
David Boder: Wer?
Toba Schiver: Die...
David Boder: Die Joint, die UNRRA? Nun und jetzt, äh, äh, plant ihr zu gehen nach Palästina?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Ihr Schwester ist ein jüngere Schwester, ja?
Toba Schiver: Ja, mit ein Jahre.
David Boder: Und sie hat sich schon verheiratet?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Warum haben Sie sich noch nicht verheiratet?
Toba Schiver: Ja, ich, ich, [unverständlich] immer noch heirate, bräuchte ein Mann dazu [unverständlich].
David Boder: Was?
Toba Schiver: [ironisch] Ich hab keinen!
David Boder: Sie haben keinen. Nun, und, äh, was wollen Sie in Palästina tun?
Toba Schiver: [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Aber Sie, haben Sie keine Verwandte in Amerika?
Toba Schiver: [Sehr leise]
David Boder: Lauter! Nein?
Toba Schiver: Wir haben zwei Cousinen und ein, äh, ein äh [unverständlich] ein Tante...
David Boder: A Tante, ja?
Toba Schiver: nach Palästina.
David Boder: Sie fahren jetzt nach Palästina?
Toba Schiver: Ja. [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Haben sie Zertifikate bekommen?
Toba Schiver: Ja.
David Boder: Na, vielleicht hätten Sie dort warten sollen, wär’s gewesen besser?
Toba Schiver: Das ist schon egal.
David Boder: Das ist schon egal.
Toba Schiver: Hab ich schon so viel mitgemacht, das [Unverständlich].
David Boder: Und was tun Sie hier den ganzen Tag?
Toba Schiver: No was, was übrige Leute. Lernen und, äh, Hebräisch und so.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Miss Toba Schiver who is rather very scarce on words. But we’ve got a, we think a significant story. We conclude this spool on 25 minutes.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Frau Schiver ich danke Ihnen sehr. Wenn Sie können bitte finden denselben Jungen, was hat sie reingebracht, schicken Sie ihn rein. Danke sehr.
David Boder: [In English] Tradate, Italy...a small locality between Como and Milano, with a community of displaced persons mainly consisting of young kibbutzim.